face à moscou les etats unis
maintiennent la pression je veux envoyer
des troupes américaines en europe peut
rester dans les pays de l'otan
prochainement un pabx ou un merci pas
plus d'informations du côté du pentagone
qui a mis en alerte en début de semaine
une 1500 soldats basés aux états-unis la
russie elle déploie toujours près de
cent mille militaires aux frontières de
l'ukraine
c'est un rassemblement de forces de plus
grande envergure ce que tout ce que nous
avons eu de mémoire récente et je pense
ce qu'il faut remonter à l'époque de la
guerre froide pour voir quelque chose de
cette ampleur
des déclarations qui tranchent avec
l'intense activité diplomatique côté
européen lors d'un appel téléphonique ce
vendredi emmanuel macron et vladimir
poutine en parlé d'une nécessaire d
escalade mais sans faire bouger leurs
positions de son côté le président
ukrainien sous la menace permanente
d'une invasion russe appelle les
occidentaux à l'apaisement
les médias donnent l'impression que nous
sommes en guerre que nous avons des
troupes sur les routes que nous sommes
mobilisés que les gens s'enfuient ce
n'est pas le cas il n'y a pas de raison
de paniquer
dernier épisode vendredi soir moscou a
annoncé l'interdiction de son territoire
à plusieurs officiels européens accusés
de propager une politique anti russe